- This is so cute.
- Why thank you.
You had no idea what happened to me today.
I got up because I was so excited
that I thought I had a little
bit of a holiday from work.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Marlee] Until, you know, whenever it is
that feeling you have some time off.
And I got an appointment
for a blow dry at the dry bar at the mall.
You know, everybody goes to the mall
and I'm there at the mall
and suddenly get a call
come to Kelly Clarkson right now.
I had no clothes.
I had nothing to wear.
So I had to go into Nordstrom.
I had to grab some stuff off the racks.
I got some socks, I got a bra.
I got everything.
And here I am.
I feel like Cinderella
- I Dream of Jeanie. That was awesome.
- This is a crazy time
because people are just
dropping left or right of Covid.
So it's like last minute
we'll be like, okay.
And so we'll ask our friends that we love
cause we love you so much.
So we are excited you could come here.
We asked for you to come.
- [Marlee] Anything for you.
- [Kelly] I love you.
And I just have a quick question.
Did you do the triple
points thing at Nordstrom?
Since you were there.
- I didn't even know about that.
- [Kelly] Oh
- I'm gonna go back right
after this. Right after this,
and get my triple points.
- [Kelly] You missed out
on a deal is all I'm saying.
So also everybody please
welcome Marley's interpreter
and producing partner.
Jack Jason, come on ya'll.
[Applause]
- Wait, you were just talking about Covid?
- Yeah
- You know I got tested,
I mean the guy came in
to blow my hair and then
I had to get tested while I
was getting my hair blown.
- It's a twofer
- Boom was like, what is she doing?
She's getting tested
while I'm doing her hair?
- It's so funny how we've all just
become accustomed to strange people being
in our nostrils and everything.
Like in your home.
Like it's just insane.
- It's the new normal.
What are you gonna say?
- It is.
Yeah, my kids know no other
world cause they're so young.
But I wanna say congrats on
the historic win for her movie
CODA. Last year,
[Cheering]
we were so stoked for y'all.
We had the whole cast here.
I fell in love
with them all over again,
even after the movie.
It was so beautiful.
What did y'all do that night?
- Well we went, let's see, I think right
after we went to the governor's
ball, to the parties there
to the Vanity Fair, people
were left and right.
I mean usually people don't
come up to me cause they're shy.
They think I'm deaf and I can't talk.
But they came right up to me and they
they said like this, you
know, they deaf applause.
And then we went to Vanity Fair.
I mean my bedtime is nine o'clock
8:30, 9 o'clock and I
was up till one and two.
And I was like, okay guys, I'm outta here.
- I, yeah, but your CODA co-star
Daniel Durant competed in
Dancing with the Stars.
So that was last season.
Did you ever get a chance to go watch him?
- I absolutely did.
I was there, me and Troy Kotzer
we were like the proud onscreen parents
for Daniel visiting our son
on Dancing With the Stars.
And we rooted him on, and
he is such a great dancer.
He's in a different place here, you know
watching him dance as opposed to acting.
He totally outside of the box.
We were so proud of him.
- Do you like dancing?
I love dancing.
- I like dancing, but I don't know
about being in front of 25 million people
and then having them
vote for me about that.
I don't know if I like that.
- No, no, no.
I just meant dancing in general.
I think it feels so good.
- Yeah!
Yeah. Yeah.
I loved to dance. Anytime,
anywhere, anybody.
- Oh, you know she didn't even have a bar.
Anybody. That's amazing.
So wait, this is important.
You've joined the board of Governors
at the Academy since we last saw you.
So what exactly does it
mean to be a governor?
- I joined the board of
the Academy with, you know
the people give out the Oscars.
So now I'm there.
I mean, it's part of, in
addition to what I do as an actor
and we're involved with changing
rules, making new decisions
and making noise about
what we need to do and to
approve inclusivity, how
to make things better
at the Academy.
And they've been nothing but
receptive, very supportive
of my community of what we need.
I mean, if we go to any of
their events, they always
have interpreters there or
any of the videos they show
they provide them with captions.
So I'm really honored to be
on the board of Governors at the Academy.
- It's so important. Yeah.
It's so important. And I
think people know, you know
even recognize it more
so now because of CODA.
Like because of a beautiful piece
of art that touched so many people
that that is what changed
it, that domino effect.
So CODA brought much needed attention
like I said, to deaf accessibility.
So what's something that you
still hope to see improved?
- I still hope to see more,
I guess stories having to do
with deaf characters with our culture.
More deaf actors, directors, writers
deaf people behind the cameras working
as in crew members in our industry.
I wanna see more of that.
- You know, what's interesting about that?
Because you know, they're
gonna have a different take
on it behind the camera
of what you see, how
they experience a film and how
they experience performance.
That's so important to
have somebody on stage.
- Absolutely. Absolutely. Absolutely.
It is.
- What can you tell us about the new show?
This is Accused, right?
- So this is something that
I've always wanted to do
for the longest time.
And I flirted with this idea
of doing something different
than what I've been doing,
which is now directing.
And I directed episodic television
a new show called
Accused for Fox and Sony.
And it's an anthology series, which means
that each episode is like a little movie
and every week there's a different story.
It's a great show and I'm
really excited and particularly
because it's my episode
and I've directed it.
- I love that.
Have you always wanted to direct
have you always wanted to
do stuff behind the scenes?
- Yeah, I've always wanted
to direct because I, you know
I have deaf eyes, so
there's something on top
of what everybody else has.
- Yeah.
- I'm more visual.
I'm always watching things
and how things work on a set.
And now that I'm behind
the camera and working
with actors, it's so much fun for me.
I mean, I get to work
with actors one-on-one
watching how they develop
their characters, watching how
they express themselves.
And you know, as an actor,
that was a lot of fun to
be able to watch them.
And I had deaf characters
and deaf actors to work with.
There was no barriers with hearing actors.
It's great. Of course.
Naturally I had
interpreters and the set was
filled with interpreters
everywhere left and right
and it was very accessible.
But in terms of working with
the hearing actors, clearly
I used an, an interpreter
who was from Canada
and I love Canada by the way.
But she was so polite as Canadians are
and she's a good friend of
mine. Her name is Susie.
I'm calling her out and she was so nice.
But when I was really animated
and I wanted to get really
into the script, I was
looking at her and she was
like talking so politely and
talking with her soft voice.
I'm like, wait a minute, I
can't use that interpreter.
I just decided to just speak myself.
And that's what I did.
- You needed the passion behind it.
- Absolutely got into it.
But yeah, it's an interesting
process and it was
an interesting journey for me.
And being the first deaf member
of the Director's Guild
of America is amazing.
- What a cool thing.
- That means what? That means what?
Open doors
for other deaf directors.
- Opening doors.
Yeah.
Which is so important.
And, and what is your
episode that you directed?
What's it about?
What is it kind of entail?
- My episode is about a deaf
woman who has decided to
be a surrogate.
And it's for a woman who is hearing.
And it just so happens
that after the baby is
born, it's born deaf
but it has nothing to
do with her being deaf.
And we see the journey
and the dynamics that go,
that she goes through.
The show is, it starts with something
about a courtroom, but you don't
know what's going to happen
and what the person is accused of.
And so the whole episode plays out
and you can see what
happens along their journey.
- Good tease.
That was a nice tease.
Okay, so I have to bring
this up because like me
you're a fan of tattoos, which
we've talked about before
but there's one that
means a lot to you, right?
- So I'm looking at the sunflowers here.
- Yes.
- And it's making me think of my mom.
I have her sunflower on my shoulder.
So she had a sunflower tattoo
and I have a sunflower tattoo.
That's my mom there?
- I have a sunflower tattoo.
Right here.
- There's mine.
- I love sunflowers.
Oh. Oh, that's beautiful.
That's really beautiful.
I love that. It's so funny.
I have a sunflower tattoo and I also
my mother was against tattoos, you know
kind of religiously like growing up.
Your body's a temple, you're
not supposed to do that.
Oh well.
And 20 later, my temple, it's my design.
So we convinced my sister
and I convinced her to do a
tattoo finally, like one year.
And she ended up getting
she's the sun and I'm the
moon, which I have that tattoo
and my sister has a star and
we're both inside the sun.
So it's like, it can be a
really cool thing. Yeah.
- Because my mom had one and
I got it for her birthday.
You know, she's Jewish
and Jews don't do tattoos.
- Yeah.
- But I think I got it
for her 65th birthday I think it was.
And then unfortunately years
later, she had Alzheimer's.
And I said to my brother
please can you take a picture of it?
Cause I can't remember
which shoulder she had it on
on her left or right shoulder
because I wanted the
same tattoo for myself.
And he tried to take a picture
of her but she's like, what are you doing?
And so we struggled to
get for like six months.
And then finally we said, mom
we need a picture of your tattoo.
And she goes, what tattoo?
- Oh.
- Because she forgot. She forgot.
But we got a picture on the left shoulder
so I got the same thing.
And there we go.
- That's beautiful though.
Have her with you.
I love that.
So what you got into TikTok last year?
I need to show the world this.
Here's you doing the
whipped cream challenge.
- What?
- Missed it?
- Merry Christmas.
- Look at the dog. And the dog.
- The dog. The dog is like,
I love this challenge.
- Are you...
- Very happy.
- Are you ou still into TikTok?
- I'm going to get more into it.
I have plans to get into it.
I can't decide, you
know, what we're gonna do
for filming the world, what
our family is doing, just
like everybody else is doing
with their families we'll see.
- Yeah.
I loved how not one of you
was like excellent at it.
I mean, it's a weird talent to have.
- It's a mess. It's a big mess. It's fun.
You should try it with your kids.
- I know.
I honestly, they would any,
any way they can inhale sugar
they'd be into it.
So yeah, I'm gonna do
it with like broccoli.
It's the broccoli challenge.
- If I wasn't an actor, I
probably would own a candy store.
- Oh, now my daughter wants
either she wants to run
a candy store or bakery.
I'm like, all right.
- Both.
- Yeah. I'm like, I like
those things. It's fine.